For everyone out there looking
to get #vaxxedandrelaxed this summer,
Grub Street reports it's officially cosmo season.
Hey, my favorite season.
They say Carrie Bradshaw's favorite cocktail
is the drink of the summer.
It's spring but you can always start early, right, Ross-y?
Cosmo MG.
Do you remember, this summer,
during lockdown, cosmos had a new life
when Barefoot Contessa, Ina Garten,
did her version of the,
look at the cosmo she made.
Remember that?
I like her.
I like her for every reason.
Ina Garten, we would give anything
to work with you.
Yeah, and you know what?
Now that I've seen your cocktail,
I'm a little jealous of, hold on.
(Ross grunting)
Thank you, okay, I got this.
I mean, that's...
She inspired me.
That's an Ina cocktail.
Thank you so much.
And you know what I think we need to call that?
What?
The Rossmo.
Okay.
Okay, Drew.
Right, how did I think of that and not you?
I don't know, now I'm thinking one for Drew
but I need a minute.
You know what I did this weekend?
I told you I was up in Connecticut,
we were driving around.
Do you love just looking at houses?
There were a couple open houses
and I went in 'cause I'm obsessed with real estate, right?
Real estate is my porn.
Well, you're not alone, Drew.
I new survey confirms that we already knew.
America is Zillow obsessed.
House Beautiful reports a survey
of 1,000 people found that 49% of people
would rather look at Zillow, that real estate app,
than have sex.
(both chuckling)
That's not all.
58% have missed a deadline at work
because they're scrolling through Zillow.
I believe that.
56% of people admit they canceled plans
with friends just to scroll and browse Zillow.
All right, that one is odd.
Okay, I love this one.
63% of people say they've looked up the value
of their friend's house,
which I was shocked that it was that low because.
Rude.
It's so rude but..
Oh, naughty.
Have you ever done it?
No, I haven't but I never thought to do it.
(Drew chuckling)
And then there's a last deet I found interesting too.
Yes, 64% of people have contacted an agent
for a home that they can't afford.
Well, come on, the real estate game
is I'm gonna show you something
that's above your price range
so you fall in love with it
and find a way to make it work.
I don't like looking at the houses,
if I'm really shopping for something
that's out of my price range
because it's just like, it's just gonna.
Torture.
It's torture.
And then you get your house, you're like whatever.
We all sometimes need to get out
of our own lives
and fanaticize about a different one.
And there's something about a house
that is like the anchor to dreaming
about being, doing something else.
It's such an outlet.
It is, it's aspirational.
I get design ideas looking at people's houses.
And I get ideas of what not to do.
I've seen some of your living rooms
where you're like nope.
Not to judge but a little bit.
It's fun, I don't know.
Sometimes for me, it's an escapism.
Yeah.
Recently I was just having such a hard time
with kids, homeschool,
I was just hitting a wall
and I started looking on Zillow at other places
and the coolest thing happened.
What?
I realized I loved exactly where I am.
Oh, Drew Barrymore, you look a left turn.
I didn't see that happening.
(upbeat music)